we can now speak to sean who is in kabul
and witnessed events near the airport
this afternoon uh thanks very much
indeed for speaking to us can you
describe the scene there on the ground
yeah uh it was around the six o'clock
the local time here at evening
and i was there with my family with my
daughter and
my wife
and
actually this explosion what happened in
the north gate of uh airport
so there's a canal water canal and
there was uh
i think
around 100 to two to 500 young
man also there there they were trying to
reach to the airport and i was there
with my family and uh before the
explosion
i i i we just decided to go back home
because
because we couldn't go we couldn't make
way to go inside the airport
and suddenly we heard a very large
and you know huge explosion over there
and then i saw that
smoke
everywhere
tell us about um
the situation as soon as the explosion
happened did
people uh manage to leave the area were
they forced to stay what is the
situation on the ground
uh well
uh the what the explosion happened
and uh
certainly you know
the people spread out everywhere and
there was a lot of people they were
wounded and even some people watched
i i've seen some people that
they are trying to get out but they were
bleeding
and they were wounded and
i've seen some people with some some
other people trying to get out of the
area
but on the spot we are we had this
explosion happen
and there
lots of people called the knife kids
their great great great amount of people
that they were they were wounded
sean tell us about the mood and
atmosphere in kabul what what are people
feeling about the situation now of
course there were thousands of people
hoping to get out on these flights many
people going to the borders with
pakistan and iran
how do people there feel right now there
must be a lot of desperation and sadness
yeah that's right lots of people that
they are they're trying to get out of
get off the country from different
borders pakistan borders pakistan
borders
and another borders which are located
which are connected to the afghanistan
the people over here they have a fear
they have a fear of
of the future
and trust me we don't have any more any
identity and even i myself
i can't see anything from my future here
like me there are there are thousands of
other young people
with the young family
and they they can see their future in
the tournament and so it's transparent
ten ten days ago the taliban came here
in kabul
and
i can say that
hundred thousand maybe more than hundred
thousand they just did these videos left
afghanistan and they went if we were
even to pakistan to
teach you to okay sure we're going to
leave it there thanks very much indeed
for speaking to us